[cheers and applause]
(Cristela)
So I'm in my 30s,
and I've only had one boyfriend
in my life.
And I think it's weird too,
because I'm obviously so pretty.
But...
(woman)
Whoo-whoo!
Thanks.
That's my mom.
[laughter]
??
Oh, no, no.
I also have to tell you that
I have a thing for Jewish guys.
I love Jewish guys.
Like, you know how guys get
excited when they see, like...
[laughter]
Hey.
[laughs]
[cheers and applause]
Where did you get
that Spanish from?
It's because I grew up
in South Texas,
and I grew up
with Mexicans,
so then when I moved
to New York,
I thought Jewish guys
were so exotic
that I was like,
"Oh, my God."
I, like, yeah!
[laughter and applause]
So I was doing an open mic,
and I met this guy,
and he was a stand-up comic too.
He still is.
And we started talking,
and he was really nerdy,
like, pale, black glasses,
you know,
and I was like,
"Yes, this guy," and...
30 minutes into
the conversation,
he tells me he's Jewish,
and in my, like, I'm like,
"Oh, that's cool,"
but in my mind, I'm like...
[imitates alarm blaring]
Like, love it, right?
I'm like,
"Oh, I'm on board, right?"
It was a Jewish guy in Dallas.
It was like a unicorn,
and...
[laughter]
We ended up going out on a date,
and he tells on the date
that he is a part-time cop.
And I have a fear of cops,
because they tend to be
not nice to me in my life,
so we went out
on our first date,
and we ended up hitting it off.
We started dating.
We're, like, maybe a month
into dating, right?
And we decide
that we're gonna have
a romantic trip to New York.
We're gonna go on Thanksgiving,
right?
And we're so excited,
and I'm, like, loving it,
and the moment we started
planning the trip,
he becomes Clark Griswold
from National Lampoon.
It's, like,
he gets really anal.
He's like, "All right,
we're gonna go traveling."
That's my Jewish accent.
And he's like,
"We're gonna go traveling,
"and we need to make it easy
for security,
"so don't wear any belts
to set off the metal detector.
"Don't put on any shoes
with laces.
"Like, save time,
liquids, gels, 3 ounces,
blah, blah, blah,"
you know.
I'm like,
"Yeah, I've flown before."
Thank you.
So then we go,
and we get in line
at the security line,
right?
And this guy, he's just like,
"Hey, remember, man, like,
if you're wearing a belt,
take off your"--
I'm like, "I get this, okay?
I'm not wearing a belt.
Good."
We get in the security line.
I go through.
No problem, right?
He gets in the other line,
and he walks through,
and then all of a sudden,
it's like...
[makes squeaking noise]
His bag, right?
So they're like,
"Whoa, whoa
There's something with the bag.
We've got to look inside
the bag," right?
Looks inside the bag.
This old white guy
who works at TSA is like,
"Whoa, we've got to
shut security down."
Shuts security down.
They sent 200 people away
to another security gate.
We don't know why,
right?
This guy, the old white guy,
starts swabbing the bag, right?
And it comes back positive
for explosives.
Then I hear
the old white guy say,
"Whoa, Nelly."
[laughter]
The guy looks at the bottom
of the bag
and takes out
a .40-caliber Glock.
[laughter]
I start thinking,
"Oh, my God.
This is not [bleep]ing
happening.
[laughter and applause]
They get the gun.
They put me against the wall.
They pad me down.
Mind you, my white boyfriend
isn't getting any
of this shit.
They're like,
"Oh, you brought the gun?
Brown girl,
come here."
It's like,
"Oh, all right."
This is weird,
all right."
So after that, they have to call
the police department
that he was a cop to make sure
he wasn't lying.
They verify,
"Hey, he's a real cop," right?
They let us go.
I go to the plane, and I think,
"[bleep] this guy,
"if I never see him again.
I'm going to New York
by myself," right.
He sits next to me,
and the entire time,
we're just sitting like this.
I'm looking outside the window.
He looks like this.
He's looking at me.
An hour into the flight,
I finally look at him and say,
"Well, at least the [bleep]ing
belt didn't set off
the [bleep]ing metal detector."
Thank you.